[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine
handball le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines a fait le
plein avec le match de handball féminin
ici paris contre brest plus de cinq
mille quatre cents spectateurs étaient
présents pour assister à la victoire sur
le fil des parisiennes plus de détails à
suivre
handball toujours l'équipe senior de
versailles a réalisé la bonne opération
de ce week-end dans le championnat de
prénationale les hommes de la cité
royale se sont imposés contre travail
accentuent leur avance sur la course au
maintien
le résumé dans ce magazine ultimate le
club zéro gènes de plaisir a fêté ce
week-end ses 20 ans pour célébrer cet
événement les plaisirs on va en profiter
de la 13e édition de leur tournoi local
baptisé zéro peine huit équipes et une
centaine de joueurs sont venus de la
région francilienne pour participer à
l'événement gros plan à présent sur les
principaux résultats du week-end dans le
département
[Musique]
on ouvre ce magazine par du handball et
le choc de première division entre les
clubs d'ici paris de brest un match de
prestige qui s'est déroulé ce samedi
soir pour la première fois au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
poussés par plus de cinq mille quatre
cents spectateurs les parisiennes ont
réussi à arracher la victoire 24 à 23
après avoir été malmené pendant les
trente premières minutes au classement
issy paris s'empare de la deuxième place
devant son adversaire du jour
on écoute les réactions à la fin de la
ronde
ça serait ça c'est le premier match
cette année quand on gagne d'accord
quand grosse équipe et
on a on n'a rien lâché c'était être au
vert faisant pas surpris je pense que ce
soir j'étais cgt de là la même chose là
de part et d'autre qui fait la
différence c'est que ici à mieux gérer
les temps faibles et ea ils ont mis les
ballons qu'ils avaient à mettre au fond
la performance était également dans les
tribunes les dix régions d'ici pas
réussi à remplir en intégralité le
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
avec plus de cinq mille quatre cents
spectateurs pour ce match délocalisé une
première pour la structure depuis les
championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste en 2015 retour sur cet événement
les images sont signés à nicolas d'ombré
17h30 vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines plusieurs milliers
de supporters arrivent pour assister au
choc de d1 féminine entre issy paris et
brest voir les pouvoirs le match idéal
on est là parce qu'on a deux joueurs de
hand et que voilà on c'est un événement
dans le coin qui est super sympa donc on
y vient en famille on est content d'être
là du monde il y en avait le match
délocalisé se jouent à guichet fermé
avec 5415 spectateurs dans les travées
cette affluence permet de dépasser le
précédent record pour un match de
handball féminin qui était jusqu'ici
détenu par nantes avec 5125 supporters
le record était effectivement une envie
pas forcément l'objectif principal
objectif principal secteur
de réussir l'événement avec tout le
territoire et historique
alors ça c'est là je suis je suis très
heureux de ça techniquement c'est réussi
pour ce premier match de handball de
l'histoire organisé dans l'enceinte
sportive certains n'ont pas hésité à
faire 600 km pour venir assister à la
rencontre et mettre l'ambiance
nous on suit toujours de très quelques
favoris de soutenir le président
rhodanien emballages on essaye de
séduire les déplacements à chaque fois
qu'on peut et c'est vrai que ici dans
cette enceinte de du vélodrome c'est
parfait se croirait à la rédac brest ce
supporter de brest avait moins le
sourire à la fin de la rencontre le
match s'achève avec une victoire au
forceps d'ici paris contre les bretonnes
sur le score de 24 à 23 selon les
joueuses parisiennes l'appui du public a
été primordiale dans ce résultat
gross et franchement on avait à coeur de
bien faire ici mais montrer que le
succès rencontré cette année le
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
et le club d'issy paris envisage déjà un
second partenariat pour l'année
prochaine cela mérite bien un clapping
[Musique]
on continue à parler de handball en
prénationale masculine l'équipe senior
de versailles recevait sur son terrain
draveil à l'occasion de la 16e journée
du championnat
les versaillais ont assuré l'essentiel
en l'emportant gymnase maubon sur le
score de 29 à 27 et se rassure dans la
course au maintien
un montage de xavier jallais le
versailles handball club s'est fait peur
ce dimanche 26 mars à domicile en tête
du début à la fin de la rencontre les
bleus et roses ont réussi à s'extirper
du piège tendu par le dernier du
classement draveil pour l'emporter 29 à
27 dans leur gymnase mon bon on a mené
tout le match on mérite de cette
victoire mais on s'est fait peur c'est
pour ça que je dis soulagée
mené de cinq buts à quatre minutes de la
fin on gagne que 2 2
guillemet mais bon je vais aussi des
matchs où cela on peut les perdre ou
faire match nul est finalement la gagne
donc l'essentiel est fait et je félicite
les gars pour la victoire notre apport
offensif était bon mais ensuite on s'est
un peu endormi sur nos lauriers on peut
un peu cru que c'était déjà fait à cinq
minutes de la fin alors qu'on aurait pu
on aurait dû continuer continuer leur
mettre au défi physique au hasard cette
performance est une véritable bouffée
d'oxygène pour les versaillais au
classement les hommes de la cité royale
reste 6e du championnat mais accentuent
leur avance sur le premier relégable y
compte désormais trois points de plus
que val de seine on va pouvoir grignoter
cette cinquième place qui je pense est
beaucoup plus à la hauteur de notre
équipe mais c'est loin d'être fait chaud
pas de le dire il faut pour cela gagner
a prioritairement les trois prochains a
dit dans un premier temps et je dirai à
mon avis les trois d'après aussi encore
donc pour l'instant on pense on et
assureront le maintien c'est à dire les
trois prochains matches les versaillais
se rendront ce samedi 1er avril sur le
terrain de saint-ouen-l'aumône un autre
concurrent direct dans la course au
maintien
chez les filles en nationale 2 l'équipe
senior de montigny-le-bretonneux est
reparti avec la victoire de son
déplacement à beauvais pour le compte de
la 14e journée du championnat le score
26 à 23 pour les y monte n
au classement les yvelinois se retrouve
5e l'objectif fixé en début de saison
ils peuvent encore espérer terminer dans
le top 4 d'ici la fin du championnat
en football américain nouvelle déception
pour les templiers d'elancourt dans le
championnat de deuxième division les
yvelinois se sont inclinés ce samedi
soir à domicile au complexe sportif
europe contre les corsaires d'evry le
score 21 à 8 une quatrième défaite cette
saison qui pourrait condamner les élans
courtois dans la course à la montée
on écoute le directeur sportif de
l'équipe frederick henderson
ah bah là maintenant ça devient
compliqué on n'est plus totalement
maître de notre destin même si on n'a
pas des joueurs compte qu on a joué
l'équipe des corsaires d'evry sont notre
concurrent direct pour l'accession aux
play-offs
donc le fait que nous est battu mais y
en a que les pendules à l'heure et pour
eux ils ont deux matches compliqués l'on
n'a qu'un seul on peut espérer en
gagnant les derniers matches pouvoir
passé ric-rac en plus raconte lui
falloir va falloir s'y remettre
continuer à travailler parce qu'on n'a
pas vraiment le choix et prenons un peu
de hauteur dans cette édition nous
allons parler d'ultimate ce sport
collectif arrivés dans les années 80 en
france se joue avec un frisbee deux
équipes de cinq joueurs doivent
enchaîner les passes pour marquer à dans
une zone dans les yvelines on compte une
dizaine de clubs parmi eux les héros
gen2 plaisir le club célébré ce week-end
son 20e anniversaire les détails avec
nicolas d'henri les érogène de plaisir
prennent de l'âge mais aucun complexe de
vieillesse pour ce club d'ultimate
fondée en 1997
depuis cette date cette activité attire
de plus en plus de licenciés
à la base le club comptait une dizaine
d'adhérents mais a tout de suite
participé au championnat et cette année
en 2017 géant compte plus de 50 environ
54 adhérents 40 adultes et environ
en 15 juniors les vingt ans coïncide
aussi avec l'ouverture de la section
juniors donc avec une section jeunes a
titré avec un entraînement extérieur et
même hier ils ont pu la possibilité
pouvoir jouer ensemble entre juniors ça
fait 12 ans que je suis dans le club
c'est vrai que c'est émouvant de voir
qu'on arrive aux 12 au 20 ans pardon
maintenant on espère comme je vous
disais beaucoup plus on arrive à avoir
de plus en plus de licenciés le sport
commence à se faire connaître également
donc c est plutôt que du positif pour
fêter leurs vingt ans les plaisirs oies
ont profité de la 13e édition de leur
tournoi local baptisé zéro peine huit
équipes une centaine de joueurs venus de
la région francilienne
un niveau assez relevé notamment avec
les tsunamis du loin de nemours
finaliste de cette compétition
nous on est une équipe avec certains
joueurs qui jouent depuis de nombreuses
années d'autres plus débutants et
le niveau oui le niveau et est bon on
verra pour la finale finalement les
tsunamis du loing se sont inclinés face
à l'équipe expérimentée des moufles d'or
plaisir termine avant dernier du tournoi
un résultat anecdotique les érogènes ont
célébré leur anniversaire sans aucun
complexe d'infériorité
on ouvre une page voix il a permis de
sauver 51 enfants pendant son dernier
vendée globe grâce à des gemmes et des
partages sur sa page facebook et le
skipper versailles et tanguy de lamotte
ne compte pas s'arrêter là pour
promouvoir l'association initiative
coeur le navigateur de 38 ans et son
équipe ont tissé sur le premier étage de
la tour eiffel un monocoque de 18 m 2 8
tonnes l'occasion de promouvoir
l'association jusqu'au 10 mai sur le
plus célèbre monument parisien
on écoute le sportif une première fois
qu'un bateau bien sûr sur la tour
appelle donc une première mondiale c'est
venu d'une rencontre
avec les gens qui gèrent
la tour eiffel et puis les gens du
projet donc voilà on s'est dit c'est un
beau défi qu'il faut qu'on relève
ensemble et voilà on avait ce bateau là
qui étaient disponibles pour venir et
c'est vrai que c'est assez
extraordinaire notre projet vendée globe
on continue à parler du versailles et
tanguy de lamotte cas pas présent sur
les projets sportifs du skipper après
avoir bourdonné sur le dernier vendée
globe le sportif veut renouer avec des
résultats digne de son standing nous
avons posé trois questions au navigateur
sur son avenir à l'occasion d'une soirée
sur la tour eiffel regarder à la
séquence
là-haut surtout on achète un bateau plus
performants donc on va les objectifs
vont continuer de progresser
la dernière fois je visais de faire le
tour du monde en 80 jours et le
jean le cam qui avait exactement le même
bateau que moi a terminé le vendée globe
en 80 jours donc je mettais pas trop
trompé sauf que j'ai pas eu la chance de
terminer et la prochaine fois on verra
ce que nous amène ses quatre ans de
développement sur ce nouveau bateau et
savoir à peu près quel rythme on peut
boucler son vendée globe mais jérémie
beyou amis je crois qu'il a mis 78 jours
où 74
donc voilà c'est des cdd beaux objectifs
mais en tout cas l'objectif toujours
numéro 1 sur ces courses là et surtout
sur le vendée globe c'est terminé
prochain objectif c'est de t'avoir
quatre ans une campagne de quatre ans
jusqu'au prochain vendée globe
ensuite l'année prochaine ça sera la
route du rhum en solitaire jusqu'à en
guadeloupe est de nouveau en 2019 la
transat jacques vabre en double et pour
finir en 2020 l'apothéose ce sera le
point d'orgue de ce projet de nouveau le
vendée globe en solitaire le tour du
monde sans escale et sans assistance
là haut je repars avec samantha avec qui
on a fait la jacques vabre en 2015 donc
on va on se connaît un peu plus que la
dernière fois et donc on va capitaliser
là dessus c'est aussi le fort de ce
projet-là de repartir sur quatre ans
avec une équipe qu'on a qu'on a vraiment
voulu garder et après il faut avoir
confiance l'un en l'autre se respectent
et se surveiller aussi un petit peu pour
le terme de sécurité et puis ensuite
avoir les mêmes objectifs donc là de
d'aller le plus vite possible de se
faire plaisir sur l'eau et de ne pas
rentrer dans une dans une spirale
négative malgré les potentiels problèmes
et ça on peut compter sur samantha pour
être pour être positive du baseball pour
terminer ce magazine les cougars de
montilliers bretons ne seront de retour
sur les terrains ce dimanche pour leur
come back en première division les y
monte invente affronter à domicile au
stade jean maréchal les ardennes de
clermont ferrand pour cette première
journée du championnat
l'occasion pour les spectateurs de voir
en action les nouvelles recrues dont la
jeune prodige du baseball français
mélissa mahieu de retour au club des
cougars appréhende-t-il son retour dans
l'élite nous avons posé la question
alexandre couton le capitaine de
l'équipe non adhérents ça ne me fait pas
peur on connaît déjà la dernière once
est notre objectif
donc on était déjà préparé mentalement
pour ça donc pas de problème là dessus
l'objectif c'est de finir entre la 4e et
la 6e place on va éviter le barrage pour
descendre et accrocher une place en
play-offs
sur la première année on sait la fin de
7,8 sport merci d'avoir suivi on se
retrouve lundi prochain pour un nouveau
magazine d'ici là passez une excellente
semaine sportive très belle soirée sur
tv fil 78
[Musique]